Democrats roll out their climate change
plans and it is a full-scale disaster
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show that's right it is all climate
change all the time because last night
was the big CNN Town Hall on climate
change now I know you watched I know you
watched with bated breath I know you
like millions of Americans tuned in to
hear Democrats talk about how they're
gonna take away your cow and your
airplane in your car and how they're
gonna magically create sources of energy
that emerge from the buttocks of unicorn
I know that you were into every single
moment of it but if you weren't we're
gonna recap all of it for you but we
begin with the media focusing
disproportionately on a specific
narrative with regard to climate change
the narrative is not that there is a
solution available because as we will
see it turns out the solutions to
climate change are extraordinarily
difficult they require a global
cooperation that is extremely unlikely
to happen the fact is that whatever
climate change is going to happen is
largely baked into the cake already
there's future climate change that
theoretically could be prevented by
collective action but collective action
is incredibly difficult when you have
developing countries that are seeking to
better their lives of their citizens
like China or India or Brazil for
example but what the media have decided
to focus on in the absence of solutions
is the problem and this is how you know
that people aren't serious about solving
a problem when everybody focuses in on
diagnosing the problem and how bad the
other guy is then this means they don't
have a solution and there's a guy in
front with named Adam grantee she's over
at University of Pennsylvania Wharton
Business School and he once said to me
that if you want to have a useful
conversation start with the solutions if
you won't have a useless conversation
start with the problems naturally most
of our politics starts with the problems
most of our politics is now about well I
diagnosed this as a problem and then I
don't have a solution but you aren't
even diagnosing it properly and that
means you're bad what politics is not
the business of diagnosing problems
politics is the business of providing
solutions to those problems and if you
have no solution then your diagnosis is
fairly useless so what the media have
decided to do what Democrats have
decided to do because the solutions to
climate change are not easy and also
they are not really doable in the way
the Democrats are talking about and they
inflict enormous
on the American public the way Democrats
are talking about them instead they have
an alternative narrative and the
alternative narrative is Republicans are
science deniers they are climate change
deniers now you'll notice that isn't an
argument for a solution that is not an
actual solution being provided that is
not an answer that is just we are
superior we are better because we
understand science and you are a science
denier and so they focused in on the
Trump administration with this now Trump
does make that easy when he says things
like climate changes the Chinese hoax
and all of that now I don't believe that
climate change is a Chinese hoax
I think the climate change is happening
I think that the majority of climate
change is man cost the reason I think
that is because even people like Roy
Spencer who is frequently quoted on
other talk radio programs who studies
this sort of stuff and is considered a
climate change skeptic even he suggests
that well over 50 percent of climate
change on planet Earth is at this point
human activity caused he's what we call
a luke warmer and the vast majority of
people who are quoted by the right who
are credible scientists are lukewarm
errs meaning that they believe that the
climate is changing they don't know
quite how much they are not sure what
the sensitivity of the climate is to
carbon emissions but they're not going
to deny that the climate has indeed been
getting warmer over the course of the
last century and a half and that
man-made activities are linked to this
Bjorn Lomborg feels this way for example
in a second we're going to discuss how
what the left does is ignore all of that
in favor of this narrative that the
Republicans just deny science wholesale
and they focus in on the most egregious
examples of this to get outraged to gin
up the idea that Republicans are
backwards and that they are cave
dwellers and all the rest of this and
all of that is really a misdirect the
misdirect from what they are actually
proposing is policy because it turns out
their solutions
suck their solutions are so bad but the
Democrats had a long conversation
internally about whether they should
have a climate change debate and the DNC
was like no we're not gonna do it so
instead they went with this townhall you
could see why they didn't want a climate
change debate because every moment of
that CNN Town Hall last night was a
Republican attack ad in the making it's
utterly unbelievable we'll get to that
in just one second first let's talk
about how you make your blinds
better-looking and by the way save on
your energy bills how well you get good
blinds okay now I know you don't think
about the blinds that you have in your
house
instead you sort of walk you know things
you know they look pretty good but they
still feels a little dingy that's cuz
you're not thinking about the window
coverings if you took a look at your
blinds you go ah and then you would want
to replace them and then when you want
to replace them you would check out
blinds calm because blinds calm makes it
really fast and really easy to shop for
the best blinds on the market which is
why I like them with 15 million windows
covered over thirty thousand five star
customer reviews blinds comm is
America's number one online retailer for
affordable quality custom window
coverings lines are a simple effective
way to make a home beautiful again they
can greatly increase the beauty and the
efficacy of your home and they make it
really easy for you blinds calm makes it
fast and easy every order gets free
samples free shipping a free online
design consultation plus if you screw it
up blinds comm will remake your blinds
for free so there really isn't even any
risk on that and they've made it
supremely easy for you for a limited
time my listeners get 20 bucks off at
blinds comm when you use promo code Ben
again omits blinds comp remote code Ben
for 20 bucks off faux wood blinds
helllloooo shades roller shades and more
blinds comm promo code Ben they make it
user friendly from soup to nuts it's
fantastic check it out blinds compro
MOCA Ben save twenty bucks
rules and restrictions do apply ok so as
I say the narrative the de media wish to
draw instead of getting into the actual
hard-nosed facts about climate change is
that Republicans deny climate change
wholesale and therefore they are stupid
and evil and terrible and as I say
president Trump tends to play into this
because he says things like climate
change is a Chinese hoax and all this
well yesterday was another opportunity
for the Democrats to smack Trump and
smack them he did that was because
President Trump did this press
conference about hurricane Torian and it
was a bizarre press conference because
he held up an outdated chart of the
storm path for hurricane Torian which
showed the possibility of hurricane
Torian hitting the entire state of
Florida and then someone had taken a
sharpie and marked in on the map that
hurricane Torian could swing into
Alabama and they did this presumably
because Trump had said that hurricanes
Orion could swing into Alabama rules it
turns out hurricanes Orion turned north
it didn't turn west and therefore there
was really no shot that it was gonna
enter Alabama
apparently instead it was going to move
up the coast into North Carolina this
drove the left upper wall it was
evidence that Trump was denying science
and that the White House was tailoring
the science in order
Trump's weird conception of reality so
the New York Times reported when
President Trump displayed a large map of
Hurricane Dorian's path in the Oval
Office on Wednesday it was hard to miss
a black line that appeared to have been
drawn to extend the storms possible path
into the state of Alabama that might
have been intended to bolster mr.
Trump's claim on Sunday when he tweeted
that in addition to Florida South
Carolina North Carolina Georgia and
Alabama will most likely be hit much
harder than anticipated
never mind that the Alabama office of
the National Weather Service quickly
responded to mr. Trump's original claim
by insisting Alabama will not see any
impacts from Dorian we repeat no impacts
from hurricanes will rain will be felt
across Alabama the system will remain
too far east so did mr. Trump who
frequently uses black sharpie pens to
sign legislation had the mark to justify
his unfounded claim about the dangers
faced by residents of the cotton state
or did someone else in his
administration clumsily modify the map
so that would appear to backup the
president there's a full-scale like
front-page story in The New York Times
that somebody took a sharpie and drew a
picture a picture on a map really why
because they're trying to draw the
narrative and the narrative is the Trump
tonight science his team denies science
and that they do solely things in order
to please him I say the black line on
the map was drawn to look like the top
of the so-called cone of uncertainty
that is familiar to weather watchers the
lyin curved through the southwest corner
of Georgia in the southeast corner of
Alabama and into the Gulf of Mexico
asked about the marking on the map Trump
told reporters he didn't know how it got
there I didn't know he said on Wednesday
well insisting that his assertion about
the dangers that Alabama faced had been
right all along
why this is a big story is beyond me
like it's it's dumb it's ridiculous but
it's a big story and it isn't beyond me
it's pretty obvious okay the reason that
this is a big story is because the
Democrats and the media but I repeat
myself
our attempting to create the narrative
and push the narrative that Republicans
deny science and so this ties directly
in to their whole take on global warming
so the big move over the last 24 48
hours has been Trump needs to leave the
White House because he's a climate
change denier now denier is again a word
that has usually been linked when you're
talking about denial of something denial
of a set of facts it's usually been
linked to things like Holocaust denier
and so it is really really overwrought
but that is the language that the left
wants to use it is a moral failing for
you to deny that climate
change is happening and then they extend
that logic out to it is a moral failing
for you to deny the solutions that we
have proposed for climate change now I
think that we should look at the best
available science the facts on the
ground and we'll go through those in
just a second and then analyze what the
solutions are that are possible
Democrats really if they had their
druthers they wouldn't talk about
solutions at all instead they would just
lay out a litany of grievances with
Republicans for not accepting the
science and that's exactly what they did
yesterday so Amy Klobuchar who is still
quixotic aliy running for president she
was appearing on national TV and she
said Trump is bad right with the big
story here is not that we have an answer
to climate change spoiler alert they
don't the big problem here is that Trump
is a bad man orange man bad we can do
this and there are so many opportunities
when you're out there and you see that
99% of the wind turbines are in rural
areas the potential for all these new
jobs and technology and we just have to
put our mind to it get the climate
denier whiner out of the White House and
see this is actually economic driver
instead of just the negative we have to
look at it it's cost-benefit it's gonna
cost them something like five hundred
billion dollars every year if we keep
doing this okay first of all that is a
really really upper level estimate as to
what it will cost us over the next
century in terms of climate change the
United States public but the key there
is the point that she's making Trump is
climate change denier climate change
denier and as well see this is the
Democrats main thrust because when it
comes down to the actual conversation
that matters namely solutions Democrats
not only have nothing they have a bunch
of ideas that are wildly unpopular with
the American people because the idea is
frankly suck and are ineffective we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about credit card debt so the
fact is credit card debt ain't going
away hey Bernie Sanders ain't relieved
in anybody's credit card debt because
that would be nuts it is also true that
it's possible that you bought into a
credit card thinking you could pay it
off and now you have all this credit
card debt it's raking in at 20% interest
rate a month and it's just terrible and
you need to do something about it as a
responsible adult well don't wait for
the government to come save you instead
figure out a responsible way to pay off
your dad's the best way to do that would
be to go to Lending Club Lending Club
allows you to consolidate your debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans no trips to a bank no high
interest credit cards just go to Lending
Club com tell them about yourself and
how much you want to borrow pick the
terms that are right for you if you're
approved your loan is automatically
deposited into your bank accounts in as
little as a few days Lending Club is the
number one peer-to-peer lending platform
with over 35 billion dollars in loans
issued go to Lending Club comm slash but
listen it's really easy to get into
credit card debt I have a lot of friends
who have done it and the best thing to
do is find a responsible way to move out
of that debt Lending Club can help you
do that check your rate in minutes
borrow up to 40 grand
that's Lending Club calm /ban Lending
Club calm /ban all loans made by web
bank member FDIC Equal Housing lender
again that's Lending Club calm /ban go
check them out right now okay so it's
not just a me Club a are doing the
orange man bad routine elizabeth warren
last night she said well trump is a
nightmare that's the real problem here
is trump is it Trump Trump Trump Trump
is bad Trump okay we'll get to their
solutions as it turns out you want to
talk about a nightmare wait until you
hear what these folks have proposed for
you and your life if they actually gain
the levers of power
here's Elizabeth Warren though pointing
out that my moral level because Trump is
a climate change denier he's a threat to
us all Beulah so quick step into the
future you win the nomination the you're
on the debate stage you're across from
the president and he says the green New
Deal is a dream because we're 60% right
now on fossil fuels you're saying you
want to put into research and get it
done but you don't know how right now
you want to bet our economy on an
ambition what's the answer
he says the Green No Deal is a dream
almost I don't know what heat is right
now is a nightmare that's not an actual
answer to the question right Cuomo asks
a very specific question which is
everything you're saying makes no sense
and she's like well you're a nightmare
whoo and she just counts on the fact
that it's a bunch of clapping seals in
the audience okay that didn't solve
anything did it right he shouldn't
answer the question but this is the
point right Bernie Sanders did the same
thing Bernie Sanders was asked about all
of this he goes well Trump's approach is
very idiotic and I know in the Artic let
me tell you I know many things about the
industry so yeah I mean I think it is
just idiotic
if you like that a president a president
takes that has that type of approach
toward climate change and again it is
forgot the word idiot it is so dangerous
it is dangerous we are the most powerful
country on earth we should be leading
the world right this is all big crap
right we're gonna will lead the world we
need to do something it's danger are you
fearing solution anywhere in here as we
will see I keep picturing this forward
because man when you hear what the
Democrats want to do to you that is
going to be really unpleasant okay that
is basically what they want to do to you
in terms of policy is basically the
first half of the movie Midnight Express
it is just awful ain't nothing good this
is happening if the Democrats get
control of the policy on climate change
and by the way it's not gonna help
climate change as we are about to see
okay and then the other thing that
Democrats do is they say well two crises
we have 11 years left and if you don't
take it seriously then you're part of
the problem here's who Lee and Castro
desperately vying for attention saying
we have 11 years left it is fun to watch
the clock tick down for Democrats we
have 12 years left no it's 11
no it's 10 no it's 1 minute if we don't
solve climate change in the next 1
minute we'll all die here's the reality
the climate is gonna change over the
next century we're going to put into
place adaptation and mitigation not
everybody is going to die there will be
cost to climate change those costs will
largely come at the expense of people
who have to move they will largely come
at the expense of some of the mitigation
efforts that we're gonna have to put in
place building new sea walls
geoengineering and all the rest you know
it will survive humanity it's gonna be
ok it's gonna be ok it'll cost us money
it ain't gonna destroy the world but
that's not a pitch so who me and Castro
was like no we're all given years to
solve this thing well then I hope he's
made his will because guess what none of
the solutions Democrats proposed are a
thing looking back with the challenge
that we have right with this UN report
that says now I guess it's 11 years that
we have left it was 12 years in 2018
when they released it I think many of us
look back and say wow you know we the
earlier we could start the better so of
course if I were mayor of San Antonio
again would I approach things a little
bit differently yeah perhaps okay guess
what he wouldn't if you're mayor of San
Antonio again he wouldn't approach
anything differently
because people San Antonio were not
gonna be super into the answers that the
Democrats are providing okay so before
we get to the answers Democrat are
providing I want to do a basic look at
the science of climate change because
there are too many people I think on the
right who are under the misimpression
that climate change is a complete
fiction that it's not happening at all
this was pushed yesterday by a guy named
James Taylor over at real clear energy
who's director of the Arthur B Robinson
Center for climate and environmental
policy at the Heartland Institute which
does do some good work and he has a
piece yesterday talking about the idea
that climate change is particularly a
hoax he says when American climate
alarmists claims to have witnessed the
effects of global warming
they must be referring to a time beyond
14 years ago that is because there has
been no warming in the United States
since at least 2005 according to the
updated data from the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration in
January 2005 NOAA began recording
temperatures at its newly built US
climate reference network us CRN
includes 114 pristinely maintained
temperature stations spaced relatively
uniformly across the lower 48 states
NOAA selected locations that were far
away from urban and land development
impacts that might artificially taint
temperature readings prior to the u.s.
CRN going online alarmist and skeptics
sparred over the accuracy of reported
temperature data with most pre-existing
temperature stations located in or near
urban settings that are subject to false
temperature signals and create their own
micro climates that change over time
government officials perform many often
controversial adjustments to the raw
temperature data skeptics of an asserted
climate crisis pointed out that most of
the reported warming in the US was
non-existent in the raw temperature data
but was added to the record by
government officials the US CRN has
eliminated the need to rely on and
adjust the data from outdated
temperature stations strikingly USCR n
temperature stations show no warming
since 2005 when the network went online
if anything US temperatures are now
slightly cooler than they were 14 years
ago case this is the piece from James
Taylor and this is sort of flying around
the internet among conservatives
yesterday saying temperature readings
show no warming absolutely no warming
since 2004 okay so a couple of things
one you if you're fair about global
warming you can't just talk about
regional warming like warming in the
United States you have to talk about the
global average temperature I emailed a
friend of mine over at Caltech who is a
climate scientist and I asked him
specifically about this data and here is
what he wrote
back and I think that it is important to
present both sides and again this is a
highly credible climate scientist at Cal
Tech he says this is cherry-picking data
generally a decade is too short to see
climate trends weather varies and the
climate change signals drought signals
drown in the weather noise on these
relatively short timescales this is the
difference between weather and climate
basically if you want to look at long
term impacts you can't look at a 10 year
period you have to look at the course of
the last century for example he says if
you put the same data from the NOAA in a
longer context you can see the clear
warming trend in the United States so
here's a chart of the warming trend in
the United States since like 1895 do we
have that chart this would be the
December average temperature anomaly
contiguous us there we go
so this is a chart from the NOAA if you
can't see this what you see is since
1900 there has been an increase in
temperature this is particularly it
warmed for the first half of the century
a little bit and then it sort of
maintained a little bit of coolness
through the 50s and the 60s and then it
starts climbing pretty radically all the
way to 2020 right so you have to
lengthen the time period so you can see
better exactly what is going on he says
even if you want to focus only on recent
temperatures from quote unquote good
stations you see an upward trend in
minimum temperatures and then he sent
over this chart which shows the upward
trend in minimum temperatures which as
you can see is a real thing right the
temperature is volatile on a
year-to-year basis but you do see a
generalized upward trend since 2000 he
says the urban heat island effect to
which the article makes known is known
to be small globally is small even on
scale of continents it does matter in
cities obviously cities tend to be
hotter than non cities okay so that's so
climate change is not a myth it is a
thing that is happening now there are
serious questions as to how much climate
change is going to happen and climate
scientists don't know whether we're
going to warm two degrees Celsius or six
degrees Celsius over the course of the
next century that is a very very large
variation obviously and there are
certain estimates that say we're at the
low end there's certain estimates that
say we are at the high end what the left
likes to do is not only take the high
end they then like to take tipping
points they like to suggest that all
sorts of horrible things are going to
happen that are unforeseeable there's
gonna be a thaw in in Antarctica and a
wooly mammoth what the Black Plague is
gonna be on earth then we're all gonna
die from that
or there's any massive tsunamis that are
going to emerge in just white major
cities from the coast lines and none of
that is predictable and all of that is
based on sheer speculation at this point
so a few things can be true at once one
human activity is creating climate
change - we don't know the sensitivity
of the climate to human activity and
three we are able to mitigate against a
lot of those effects but there's
something else that is important to know
and that is that a global solution is
not really in the offing okay this is
the hard part and the part the people on
the left don't want to acknowledge that
is the solutions to climate change that
they are proposing in the United States
are not only ineffective they're
counterproductive
they hurt American citizens they make
the rest of the world poorer and if you
actually want the rest of the world to
care about climate change in the
environment they need to be richer not
poorer their studies that show that
countries start to care about
environmentalism basically when the GDP
per capita hits about 30 100 bucks per
capita well a lot of countries don't
have that and you really think they're
gonna let their citizens continue to
burn dung in their homes which by the
way ain't great for carbon emissions
instead of using coal based energy to
create electricity plants for example in
the second I want to go through some of
the facts on climate change where is it
where the emissions actually coming from
and then we'll look at the Democratic
solutions and you will see how these
solutions are not even tailored to
solving the problem they're more
tailored to making people feel good
about themselves because Democrats know
these things will never be implemented
well get it into that in just a second
first take a look at this beautiful
watch you see this watch it's a nice
watch and this did not cost me an arm in
Oh like now I'm something of a watch
aficionado lately and I can tell you
that the value on this watch is
excellent why because it is a movement
watch MVM T okay it is spare looking it
is clean looking it is minimalist all I
want is watch this gonna tell me it tell
me the time and look good doing it and
that's what movement does they have you
covered with tons of quality clean all
around good-looking watches and
accessories that we can actually afford
an order directly from our couch with
over 2 million watches sold worldwide
movement has solidified themselves as
one of the fastest growing watch brands
out there movement watches started just
95 bucks you're definitely not breaking
the bank and you're guaranteed to find
something you love that is not gonna
cost you an arm and a leg these dudes
are truly a grounds of entrepreneur
success story
they understand that living on a tight
budget doesn't mean that you have to
look like garbage at least in terms of
your timepiece they've sold over 2
million watches across more than 160
countries their collections are always
expanding just for you I've gotten
movement watches for pretty much
everybody in my family because again
they don't cost an arm I'm cheap they
they don't cost an arm and a leg and
also they look really really good they
also have to be pretty durable get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to movement comm slash
appearance MVM t-dot-com slash appear o
see why the movement keeps growing check
out their expanding collection they also
do sunglasses I've got those two in
there great go to em VMT comm slash
Shapiro join the movement
MVM T comm slash Shapiro okay so let's
go through through some of the
information on where exactly greenhouse
gas emissions are coming from and you
can see the problem almost immediately
almost immediately here okay so
greenhouse gas emissions for major
economies what are the sources of these
emissions okay first if you look by
country what you'll see is that the
United States is basically held steady
since about 1990 in terms of its
greenhouse gas emissions it's actually
receded since the year 2000 we've
actually reduced our carbon emissions
the same thing is true for the EU which
used to be responsible for the second
most emissions as of 1990 look at this
line for China okay
China continues to elevate its
greenhouse gas emissions arithmetic Li I
mean it's it's a it's it's a an
arithmetic line from the bottom left of
a charge to the top right of the chart
and China continues to grow this way the
same thing is true of India which has
now moved into a solid fourth place and
most students were past the EU in total
greenhouse gas emissions in other words
the United States can cut down its
greenhouse gas emissions the EU can cut
down its greenhouse gas emissions
they're never going to cut those
greenhouse gas emissions down to zero
it's just not going to happen at least
not in the foreseeable future as we'll
also see in just a moment China and
India are not going to stop any of this
so if your solution is we're gonna solve
this thing in the next 10 years they're
gonna have to get China and India on
board good luck to you because if you
think that China is simply going to cut
off its access to carbon-based
carbon-based sources of energy on behalf
of global good you got another thing
coming hey China is in a competition
right now with the west and with the
United States on everything from 5g
through their through their IP stealing
company Huawei to the belt and road
system you think they're gonna cut off
that competition when it comes to an
Geel the greater likelihood is that they
sign on to some deal like for example
the Paris climate Accords and then
proceeded to do absolutely nothing my
evidence for this is that that's exactly
what they have done under the Paris
climate Accord they signed on the US
didn't we reduced our emissions China
did not okay so that's number one then
we have to look at greenhouse gas
intensity and meaning on a per capita
level on a per GDP capita level who is
actually spending the most like if
you're are you a poor country that is
disproportionately benefiting from
carbon-based emissions as you'll see
here the United States is greenhouse gas
intensity meaning the amount of
carbon-based fuel that we are using per
dollar of GDP is actually fairly low it
is places like Russia and China
developing countries that are that are
spending enormous amounts of carbon
emissions based on the GDP per capita
that they have the United States is
actually below the world average
so again China Russia developing
countries this is where the major
problem lies in terms of greenhouse gas
emissions and then we have to look at
where exactly these emissions are coming
from because there's this weird idea in
the West that this is all coming from
automobiles and eating meat no no no no
no no that's not how this works if you
look at the source of greenhouse gas
emissions by sector globally what you
see is that the vast majority of it is
coming from the energy sector the vast
majority of it is not coming from
automobiles the vast majority of it is
not coming from agriculture the vast
majority of it is coming from the energy
sector meaning electricity and heat
transportation other fuel combustion
manufacturing and construction right
that that seventy-two percent of all
emissions are not coming from for
example agriculture or land use change
in forestry or waste or industrial
processes it's coming from actual like
energy grids like people who are trying
to live in the world okay which means
that if you are looking to cut down on
greenhouse gas emissions then that
should be the sector you're targeting
but amazingly amazingly that's not the
sector that the left actually wants to
target mostly right there they're
targeting coal but they have but they
but they refuse to buy into for example
nuclear power there's something Henry
Olson writes about at the Washington
Post today he says ten Democratic
presidential hopefuls gather on
Wednesday for a climate Town Hall in
which they will lay out their plans to
combat climate change
there are two words few of them if any
are likely to mention nuclear power
voters who take climate change seriously
should demand better climate change
activists tell us that the planets
future is at stake if we don't act now
but nuclear power expansion is notably
absent from three of the four leading
Democratic candidates Climate Action
Plans Warren Harris Bernie that so
warranted Harris don't mention it at all
Sanders does mention at nuclear power
and he says he will stop construction of
all nuclear power plants and place a
moratorium under newing licenses for
existing ones now as you will see this
is complete idiot II because here is a
chart of the actual cost this is the one
that we just pulled guys the actual
chart that shows the capital and other
fixed costs of particular sources of
energy what you will see here is that by
far the capital and other fixed cost the
lowest source available energy is
conventional combined-cycle natural gas
right natural gas is the cheapest thing
to draw out which is why fracking is so
popular right now it is also true that
the emissions rate of fracking is a
natural gas is significantly lower than
that of conventional coal for example
which is one of the reasons why the
United States has reduced emissions
fracking has actually led to a reduction
in carbon emissions in the United States
because when you contrast natural gas
with conventional coal natural gas is
significantly more carbon efficient than
conventional coal then you get to the
actual costs of the other sources of
energy and what you see is the
conventional call costs leave the
estimates of cost in the near-term
electricity generation and they are
measuring they're they're measuring
basically cost per unit and so cost per
unit and capital and other fixed costs
for conventional and combined-cycle
natural gases like two dollars and five
cents against a conventional coal it's
seven dollars and five cents wind is 970
geothermal is 922 right then you get up
into solar we don't not like 21 bucks
Internet solar thermal 31 bucks advanced
natural gas is a lot lower it's closer
to conventional natural gas so what
exact Bance nuclear is not nearly as
high as solar or solar thermal in
essence what this chart shows the one
that I'm showing now this comes from
William Nordhaus is book by the
what this chart shows is that Democrats
are focusing on the most expensive least
efficient forms of energy at the expense
of the forms of energy that are most
carbon efficient and also least
expensive if you're focusing on wind and
you're focusing on thermal and solar
thermal for example and you're ignoring
advanced nuclear or you're ignoring
natural gas you're a fool
but that's exactly what Democrats are
doing now it's also important to note
here where exactly climate emissions in
the United States are coming from so
here are the percentages of emissions in
the United States by economic sector so
people keep talking about agriculture as
you'll see 9 percent of total u.s.
greenhouse gas emissions are coming from
agriculture 9 percent twenty nine
percent comes from transportation so
that B cars and buses but that's still
only 29 percent electricity and industry
represents about 50 percent of all of
the greenhouse gas emissions which means
that you're gonna knock out some of the
key industries in the United States and
raise costs for consumers in some of the
key industries of the United States
commercial and residential represents
about 12% broken down a different way
from Nord houses book if you look at
emissions for different activities by US
households in 2008 here's what you find
the percentage of emissions in the
United States for individual households
about 15 percent is from automotive
travel about 6 percent is from space
heating about 3 percent is from air
travel about 2.5 percent is from air
conditioning everything else including
non household is about 64 percent
meaning that the vast majority of the
things that the Democrats are targeting
are not the things that are actually
going to affect the carbon emissions
right and here's the problem
the problem is that there are no good
solutions for any of this because as
that chart shows the one that shows you
about the alternative sources of energy
and how in their relative costs
there ain't nothing great coming
directly on the horizon William Nordhaus
the current Nobel Prize winner in
economics writes in his book
climate casino quote the central
question going forward is the prospect
for economical low carbon act
electricity wind is the only mature
low-carbon technology it is 50 percent
more expensive than the best existing
technology moreover its capacity is
limited in the United States the other
promising technologies with the
possibility of large-scale deployments
are from least to most expensive
advanced natural gas with
carbon capture and storage this is where
you create machinery that helps
basically capture the carbon emissions
from natural gas advanced nuclear power
and advanced coal with carbon capture
there are 50 these are 50 to 100 percent
more expensive than the most economical
existing technology so even these ones
are way more expensive than just natural
gas for itself natural gas is the
cleanest of the fossil fuels as Nordhaus
emitting about half as much co2 per
kilowatt hour as coal when burned for
electricity generation shifting a
greater fraction of electricity to
natural gas is an important way of
reducing co2 emissions guess what
Democrats want to do some of them are
called ok they say they want to kill the
natural gas industry they're not
interested in nuclear power but they
want to stop you from eating meat and
using plastic straws if all the sounds
like stupid virtue signaling that is not
designed to actually solve the problem
that's because it is stupid virtue
signaling that is not designed to solve
the problem and it's because Democrats
know they're never gonna do any of this
crap we're gonna go through the
Democrats climate change plans at long
last in just one second first there are
a lot of options when it comes to
shaving products you go into the store
you're not sure what to buy plus it's
annoying because the truth is that when
by the time you realize that your razor
is too blunt for you to use now you
missed the day shaving you have to go
out to the store and you're like
backfilling your time it's ridiculous
instead you should be using Dollar Shave
Club Dollar Shave club's makes your life
easier they take out the guesswork and
they guarantee quality shaving products
first of all their razors are fantastic
second of all they've got all sorts of
other great products they've got this
Amber lavender body cleanser which is
calming and soothing and delightful I
smell delightful
right now Dollar Shave Club is way more
than just razors they've got you covered
head to toe they have everything you
need to shower shave style your hair
brush your teeth it is nice to have a
one-stop shop for all your grooming
needs and Dollar Shave Club can keep you
automatically stocked up on the products
you use you get what you want whenever
you need it whether that's once a month
or a few times a year I never have to
waste time at a store wondering if what
I'm getting is any good because I know
the Dollar Shave Club products are
top-quality right now you can put the
quality of Dollar Shave club's products
to the test their ultimate shave starter
set has basically everything you need
for an amazing ship they've got the
executive razor shave butter prep scrub
post shave do the best part is you can
try it for just five bucks
after that the restock box trips regular
sized products and regular prices so you
can try them out if you like it you keep
it going get that ultimate starter set
for just five bucks at
dollarshaveclub.com
once you start you're not gonna want to
stop that's dollarshaveclub.com / ben go
check them out right now okay we are
going to at long last get to the
democratic solutions presented last
night on CNN it is a massive campaign ad
for Republicans insane massive campaign
ad for Republicans we'll get to that in
just one second first head on over to
Daly we're calm and subscribe $9.99 a
month or 99 bucks a year gets you this
the greatest eternal beverage vessels it
is indeed magnificent also when you
subscribe you help us bring you the show
every single day a lot of folks on the
Left we don't want you to hear facts
they don't want to hear conservative
opinions and ideas well you can fight
them by joining the club and becoming
part of the team it is a great way to
help us out and help spread the message
go check us out at Daly we're calm we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so now at long last we get to
the Democrats plans on climate change as
I say what Democrats would prefer to do
is say Republicans are denying the
science
I just ran you through all the science
all of the things that I just quoted are
things from people who are deep
believers in climate change people who
are deeply concerned about climate
change they are from books from Nobel
Prize winners they are studies from the
National Ocean an oceanographic and
atmospheric administration right these
are this is all data based on the same
data that folks in the Democratic Party
are using and what I am saying is that
the only way to fight climate change in
reality is going to end up being over
the next century investing in new
technologies which is already happening
and investing in geoengineering right
trying to take tax to mitigate climate
change not by destroying people's
quality of life but by actively trying
to change the climate the only one who I
heard talk about this at all yesterday
was Andrew yang my boy Andrew yang okay
there's going to be mitigation effects
people attempting to build sea walls and
move infrastructure right though that's
that's what's going to end up happening
in reality then there's all the pie in
the sky crap Democrats are talking about
which is not going to accomplish
anything which means this is all about
virtue signaling so we're gonna go
through candidate by candidate and show
you what they say
so joe biden last night he said the
green New Deal as in like a o C's green
New Deal
you know the green new deal that was
supported by zero senators including
co-sponsors of the Green Deal he says
that that doesn't go too far you know
her 93 trillion dollar plan for the
United States economy button says that
doesn't go too far another reason he's
saying this of course is because he is
trying to force Republicans into a
position of saying that they don't care
at all about climate change he's trying
to do with climate change what Democrats
are doing with guns right now which is
we disagree on the solutions to the
problem but that means I'm denying the
problem according to the left so
according to Joe Biden and the left if I
say that you're stupid solutions are not
in fact solutions they're just dummy
that they're just dummy garbage then
that's because I'm a denier that's Joe
Biden snicker you're not saying that you
support everything in the original green
New Deal do you think it goes too far is
it unrealistic promising too much it's
not here here's what it is it doesn't
have a lot of specifics but the
I don't know I'm not opposed the green
New Deal what I did was when I thought
beyond at least in more detail what the
green New Deal is calling for how to do
the things we need to do when they have
to be done how quickly we should move
how much we should invest etcetera okay
except that he doesn't actually call for
any specificity he just wants to say
that the Green Deal is a good idea so
cuz when he gets specific carrots were
all the attack ads for Trump start last
night was a fantastic night for
president Trump listen to Joe Biden say
he's gonna shut down every coal plant in
the country you think there's gonna go
well the thing is he's not gonna invest
in advanced carbon capture technology
for coal plants he is not going to talk
really about how to move those jobs
instead we're just gonna have to shut
down all the coal plants in the United
States now the United States is
responsible on a global level for about
15 percent of all carbon emissions so
he's now talking about wiping an entire
sector off the face of the American
economy and that that sector by the way
is already in trouble largely because of
technological advances but he's talking
about forcibly killing that sector from
above to the tune of what maybe three
maybe three percent of total carbon
emissions on planet earth like that that
would be a high a real high-end estimate
here is Joe Biden we we should set out
the rules for what kind of plant you
know coal burning plants no one's gonna
build another coal burning we've got to
shut the ones down we have but no one is
gonna build a new one guess what they're
not efficient okay well he is right that
the coal plans are not efficient that
you you'd be better off building natural
gas plants there's only one problem
nuclear plants probably one problem the
same Democrats who are talking about
getting rid of coal plants are also
avoiding to talk about how exactly
they're gonna build a new plant you're
not building a you're not building a
wind farm to replace those coal plants
it is just not happening and then Biden
says you know what we'd like to reach a
point where everyone drives electric
cars that's my plan electric cars
electric cars there's only one problem
with that which is that electric cars
ain't gonna do a job and can do the job
here's a study from National Geographic
circa 2014 electric cars can help limit
reliance on imported oil and take a bite
out of air pollution from urban traffic
jams but is surefire
but as surefire ammunition against
climate change a new study finds they
come up short the study attempted to
take a big-picture view
analyzing the ripple effects of electric
vehicles on the US energy system
including possible changes in emissions
of key air pollutants like heat-trapping
carbon dioxide the team of researchers
led by Joseph D Corollas assistant
professor of civil construction and
environmental engineering at North
Carolina State University created a
model to look at the complex interplay
among fuel prices battery costs
government policies and adoption of
electric cars in the coming decades the
team modeled 108 scenarios the new model
found they reported that even in
scenarios that yield the highest levels
of electric vehicle deployment plug-ins
and hybrids would make up no more than
42 percent of all US passenger vehicles
in 2050 and would reduce overall
emissions by a slim margin a good news
is Joe Biden wants to force you to drive
one of these newfangled smart cars will
there be a point or would you like there
to be a point and if so when that
everybody drives an electric car or has
to drive an electric cars well I think
look that's going to be based upon
whether or not we can make it
economically feasible and it is
economically feasible because guess what
everybody knows where the world's going
we have to take the cake combustion
engine vehicles off the road as rapidly
as we can but that also could create a
significant number of jobs and
opportunities for people no actually
it's going to take away a significant
number of jobs because it turns out that
American heavy industry and car
companies are generally in the business
of building light trucks ok the
manufacturing in the United States is
disproportionately not in the electric
vehicle industry it also happens to be
the case that as we already referred to
only about 15 percent of household
emissions in the United States come
courtesy of your car of your car so that
actually doesn't solve the problem so
what does solve the problem according to
Joe Biden a carbon tax now the truth is
that if you had a global carbon tax to
artificially raise the price of carbon
emissions then that would be an
effective way presumably of lowering
carbon emissions there's one small
problem with that do you think that
China and India are going to saw a sign
on to a global carbon tax do you think
developing countries are going to be
into this you think this is a thing
that's going to happen and there are a
lot of people who advocate for this
including William Nordhaus I talked
about earlier this global carbon tax it
does not work if it's regional if the
United States taxes our own citizens on
carbon
and destroys our economy in the process
and presumably hurts other economies in
the process also preventing their upward
mobility because the world economy is
dependent on the United States economy
do you think that those economies are
more or less likely to rely more on
carbon-based fuels in order to spur
their economy okay a regional tax will
not work you need a global tax guess
what's the thing that is not happening
any of this here is Joe Biden talking
about why we need a carbon tax anyway
would you support a carbon tax other
some other candidates say they would ya
know III would but here's what we have
to do look the bottom line of this is
what we have to do is we have to
understand that you need to be able to
bring people and countries and interest
together to get anything done you can
have the plans are great but executing
on those plans is a very different thing
we make up and it's the existential
threat of not this generation but the
whole world the existential threat that
exists we don't move on it okay well
guess what
China ain't moving on it that's why
listen everyone who is serious about
this topic it's funny there's there's
almost like an Oreo cookie effect to
knowledge about climate change it goes
somewhat like this when you don't know a
lot about climate change you assume
there really is not a lot we can do then
you know a little bit you're like
there's so much we can do man we can
solve this thing then you know a lot
about climate change like odd there's
not that much we can do I mean
unfortunately because the
collective-action problem is too grave
and also because all of these little
measures that the Democrats are talking
about taking do not solve the problem
that do harm the economy and politically
unfeasible I mean Bernie Sanders is at
least honest about this stuff right
Bernie Sanders like I'm just gonna ruin
your life that's the wonderful thing
about Bernie Sanders Bernie has he
doesn't even attempt to sell it but he's
like yes I'm going to raise your taxes
yes I'm gonna make you stop eating meat
yes I'm going to take your car yes I'm
gonna take away your airplane I won't do
any of those things I still want my
pudding but you should do all of those
things now let's talk about raising your
taxes sounds like a great idea right
let's do this thing we have a moral
responsibility to act and act boldly and
to do that yes it is going to be
expensive and when we do that you're
gonna have a lot of taxpayers out there
who will be paying more in taxes you'll
have people who are not getting food
stamps and so forth would you guarantee
to the American public tonight that the
responsibility
for sixteen point three trillion dollars
which is a massive amount of money
wouldn't end up on taxpayers shoulders
well it'll end up on some taxpayers
shoulders if you are in the fossil fuel
industry you're gonna be paying more in
taxes that's the schwa I don't know
whatever those who are into the same
routine right was with Warren said
the fossil fuel companies are gonna pay
for this it'll be the fossil fuel
companies right fossil fuel companies
wants to talk about straws and
cheeseburgers but really they're the
ones who have to pay okay do you think
that's not gonna get passed on to you
the consumer in the same way that a
tariff is passed on to you the consumer
if you taxed the fossil fuel industry
you really think they're just gonna keep
the price the same of course not and
that's the part she's not telling you
there are a lot of ways that we try to
change our energy consumption and our
pollution and god bless all of those
ways some of it is with light bulbs some
of it is on straws some of it dang is on
cheeseburgers right but understand this
is exactly what the fossil fuel industry
hopes we're all talking about 70% of the
pollution of the carbon that we're
throwing into the air comes from three
industries and we can set our targets
and say by 2028 2030 and 2035 no more
okay you can set those targets and guess
what it ain't gonna happen because those
costs are gonna get passed on to the
American consumer that's the part that
she is not telling you about now again
at least you got to appreciate Bernie
because he just puts it out there man so
yesterday Bernie Sanders was asked about
overpopulation okay which again has not
been a problem historically on planet
Earth
and there's a lot of Malthusian theory
going around for centuries about how we
were going to overpopulate the earth
there'd be mass die-offs Paul Ehrlich
famously wrote a book called the
Population Bomb in the late 1960s
suggesting that billions would die of
starvation and hunger instead people are
living more prosperously than they ever
have and they're almost 8 billion of us
on planet Earth hey but nonetheless this
has become a sort of rote point of
contention on the left it's become just
a talking point on the left that there
are too many people Bernie Sanders he
just lays it out there he's like well
you know what if we have a problem with
carbon emissions let's just kill all the
poor people they may not be bogna as
long as they're not born yet we can kill
the poor once they are born we can't
I'm all sorts of rights but if their
unborn then we should probably pay to
have them snuffed out in the womb boom
they're not the problem anymore no
babies no carbon emissions problem
solved empowering women and educating
everyone on the need to curb population
growth seems a reasonable campaign to
enact would you be courageous enough to
discuss this issue and make it a key
feature of a plan to address climate
catastrophe well the answer is yes the
Mexico City Agreement which denies
American aid to those organizations
around the world that are that allow
women to have abortions or even get
involved in birth control to me is
totally absurd so I think especially in
poor countries around the world where
women do not necessarily want to have
large numbers of babies okay and in poor
countries we should fund abortion so
that it helps climate change that's a
hell of a pitch right there remember
five minutes ago when they were saying
the pro-life movement is racist which
makes no sense at all Bernie Sanders is
openly stating he wants fewer poor brown
babies around the world through abortion
to fight climate change that's not great
Bernie but he spells it out that's the
one thing people love about Bernie's
that that dude just lays it right out
there now the thing people hate about
comel harris is that she has a panda
bear right Kamala Harris just tries to
pander and so she is going over-the-top
yesterday on the CNN Town Hall she's
like yeah we're gonna ban everything man
we're gonna ban fracking now as I just
showed you through the charts the most
effective form of lowering climate
carbon emissions in the United States
right now is the substitution of natural
gas for coal because natural gas is
cheap and it is effective and it is a
lot lower in terms of carbon emissions
than coal naturally she wants to ban
fracking which makes tons of sense
obviously there's no question I'm in
favor of banning fracking
and starting with what we can do on day
one around public lands right and and
then there has to be legislation but yes
and this is something I've taken on in
California I have a history of working
on this issue and to your point on ok so
again we're gonna ban fracking again
quote William Nordhaus again he knows
more about this than she does shifting a
greater fraction of electricity to
natural gas is an important way of
reducing carbon emissions and she's like
let's ban fracking makes perfect sense
then you get Camilla Harris suggesting
we need to have Americans eat less meat
now if Americans want to voluntarily eat
less meat that's fine but Camilla Harris
is basically suggesting that the
government should cram down from the top
restrictions on your ability to eat meat
yeah this is gonna go over great with
the American people great by the way
again agriculture represents about 11
percent of u.s. carbon emissions hey and
global emissions agriculture does not
represent a tremendous percentage as we
showed you earlier in the program
here's Kamala Harris saying we need to
get people to stop eating meat also she
wants to ban plastic straws you can play
those back-to-back we the balance that
we have to strike here frankly is about
what government can and should do around
creating incentives and then banning
certain behaviors I mean just to be very
honest with you I love cheeseburgers
from time to time right I mean I just do
and I think that but there is but there
has to be also what we do in terms of
creating incentives that we will eat in
a healthy way that we will encourage
moderation and that we will be educated
about the effect of our eating habits on
our environment and we have to do a much
better job of that and the government
has to do a much better job of that okay
and then she called for a ban on plastic
straws as well because she's the white
Andrew yang competing with her he said
we should eliminate commercial air
traffic like this is a hell of a pitch
guys if Democrats really believe that
the way to win the hearts and minds of
Americans is to eliminate air travel
raise your taxes increase your energy
prices and do all of this without
significantly affecting carbon emissions
because there is no global deal in place
and because there is no new technology
on the horizon that is going to replace
carbon-based fuels at the moment those
technologies may arise when they enter
Eisen right now instead of focusing in
on mitigation and adaptation which are
the other sides of the coin again you
can do something about climate change
it may not be targeting you
Birger it may be about building sea
walls it may be about geoengineering and
figuring out how to change the climate
by creating cloud cover there are things
we can do paint the things the Democrats
are talking about and you know what the
Democrats know that the Democrats know
that because what the Democrats really
want from all of this is to look like
they are willing to do anything to stop
climate change the problem is the
American people are not the people of
the world are not other countries are
not until basically this is a bunch of
virtue signaling nonsense that is really
going to come back and bite them
directly in the ass in the 2020
presidential election so good for them
they want to own it enjoy okay time for
a quick thing that I like and then we'll
do a quick thing that I hate so things
that I like today first of all I do not
understand people making a big deal out
of Joe Biden having a birth blood vessel
like this was the headline at Drudge
that Joe Biden has a burst blood vessel
you can actually see this burst blood
vessel in his eye and I get it I mean I
know everybody's like an I beheld when
he had opened the sixth seal and lo
there was a great earthquake and the Sun
became black as sackcloth of hair and
the moon became as blood and people oh
he has a bloody eye
my wife saw this last night she is a
doctor and my wife was like no that's
not a thing
like who cares that is not a sign of ill
health that is not a sign of being
elderly that is simply a sub
conjunctival hemorrhage okay it can be
caused by a lot of stuff but it does not
have to be caused by just being an old
person nonetheless people made a big
deal out of it the Internet is a funny
place and thus there were many funny
memes about all of this but I will say
that Joe Biden has been handling his
lack of ability on the on the world
stage and on the campaign stage with a
fair bit of good humor so Biden was on
Stephen Colbert last night and he said
the only thing that's been said that's
funny on Stephen Colbert for years
actually you want to talk about issues
but a lot of people want to talk about
your gaps you have called yourself a
gaffe machine okay do you you in the
last few weeks you've confused New
Hampshire for Vermont said Bobby Kennedy
and MLK were assassinated in the late
70s assured us I'm not going nuts
follow-up question are you going nuts
the reason I came on the Jimmy Kimmel
show is because I there is Joe Biden
again Joe Biden a little self effacing
humor goes a long way and it's something
that if President Trump had self
effacing humor would really serve him
pretty well okay final thing that I like
we're gonna skip things I hate today
because we're out of time but final
thing that I like so Bernie Sanders was
asked yesterday if he would cancel all
credit card debt and he has no answer to
this question because Bernie Sanders is
basic program is that everything will be
paid for by some deus ex machina called
the rich I don't know who the rich are
that are going to pay for all this stuff
and I also don't know what his limiting
principle is on simply relieving people
of their debt neither does Bernie
Sanders that became perfectly obvious in
this exchange let's say you win the
nomination very good chance of that
you're running now in the general
election against President Trump in the
Republicans and they're gonna say what
Bernie Sanders wants to wipe out college
loan debt you know he wants to wipe out
medical debt what's next are you gonna
wipe out credit card debt I mean how do
you push back I think there's a
difference no I don't not here to talk
about I don't believe we've wiped that
credit card you know you want to buy
something you pay for it but I do
believe we have to make a distinction
well you want to buy something you pay
for unless we're talking about college
tuition or your health care or any of
the other products that I want to
relieve that from if you rack up charges
on your credit card well then you're on
your own if Bernie Sanders I have a
feeling I think gonna last for very long
I mean honestly I don't know why he
doesn't just go here like really why
doesn't he just go here you know he
wants to you know deep in the recesses
of Bernie Sanders peculiar brain there's
a small voice a small weird Brooklyn
voice going do it bunny do it tell them
that you will relieve all credit card
debt do it you can do this you know that
he wants to and sooner or later that
will break free and be like I'm
relieving all the mortgages and I'm
getting rid of credit card debt in fact
we will call it Jubilee year and we'll
just relieve all the debt like in the
Bible which I've never read it will be
great
Bernie Sanders that dudes the best I do
love that Bernie Sanders again he can't
help but be honest and his honesty is
it's bracing man
it is bracing all right well we will be
back here a little bit later today with
two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
we've already reached nearly the end of
the week guys because we had a short
week this week so congratulations to us
we'll see you here a little bit later
I'm Ben
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Caro Mina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2019 on the Matt Walsh show we're not
just discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you